we are pleased to announce Android 2.3
the fastest version of Android yet in
Android 2.3 we focused on optimizing
performance and tools for game
development supporting open media
formats and tools for content creators
and bringing new and innovative forms of
communication into our mobile platform
in Android 2.3 we're taking gaming to
the next level game developers always
want the best performance so we've given
them what they asked for
in Android 2.3 first we introduced a new
concurrent garbage collector for the
dalvik VM it minimizes application
pauses which leads to smoother animation
and increase responsiveness
we also fine-tuned input handling for
charge and key events this Howard CPU
usage and increase the dispatch speed to
make it easier to bring high-performance
games to Android we broadened the native
API is exposed by the platform
developers have direct access to input
and sensor events audio OpenGL ES and
assets and there is a new native
framework for lifecycle and window
management we also provided one of the
first implementations of the Khronos
group opensl es standard for native
audio for games that use motion
processing we've added support for a
gyroscope and other new sensors a great
multimedia environment is key to
developing exciting games and apps with
Android 2.3 we are giving developers
more ways to use audio and video for
example where any support for vp8 and
WebM which are new open video standards
we're also adding support for AAC and
AMR wideband encoding as well as new
audio effects like reverb headphone
virtualization and bass boost
applications can use these effects
globally or on a per track basis to
create a truly immersive audio
experience here's a look at a graphic
equaliser that uses the audio effects
we've extended the camera API so that
applications can access any number of
cameras available in the device taking
advantage of the unique characteristics
of each one applications can still
access the back facing camera for images
that need better resolution while the
front-facing camera is perfect for video
chat Android 2.3 includes a built-in sip
stack and an application API on
supported devices developers can write
applications that offer audio calling it
is fully integrated inside the
application itself the API is easy to
use and lets you set up audio calls of
any other sip client even on another sip
enabled device in this release one of
the features that I'm really excited
about is near field communication I've
been working to bring this to the
platform device with can scan attack to
quickly read URLs or any other data
format that you desire there are so many
possibilities for what a developer can
do with this technology these are just a
few highlights of what you'll find in
Android 2.3 to learn more visit
developer.android.com